how she is with us she is an author and
also a professor what do you teach I
teach a wide range of humanities
literature or history media and we're
the University of the Arts in
Philadelphia did you know that you are
in the paper today
know about what let's pull this one out
and we'll just start right here with the
Style section of the Washington Post
this morning and a little article on the
side called the spice search you know
there's they're looking for someone to
replace I'm not very good at this which
one one of the Spice Girls yeah the
ginger yes and so that they the
Washington Post has put together a list
of possible names people who could
replace her and actually you're you are
one of them right here
what are you they call you snarly spice
oh great what do you think about having
all that in our life I think has a very
good role model for women I think women
shouldn't be as nasty as possible why
should they be nasty because women have
been a no nodding and smiling and giving
men support from behind the scenes for
years it's about time women take stage
now they also name some other people
Martha Stewart they call her really
scary spice Oh Vernon Jordan Akin Gump
Strauss Hauer Feld and spice Courtney
Love smacking and Bob Hope Old Spice
which is when to keep going
now also in USA Today there is a more
serious story but about the same thing a
woman Diane McWhorter who's a a writer
in New York talks about the whole issue
of the Spice Girls and her young
daughter she says that the band is a
true is a triumph of commerce over art
is not noteworthy in the culture that
has made a cardinal virtue of celebrity
what is remarkable and little remarked
upon is that like the Beatles the Spice
Girls have managed to make a significant
political mark on a generation of fans
the band's true appeal to young girls is
the ideal ideology sweetly summed up in
its slogan girl power if I think they
have been a very positive influence on
young kids 12 13 I mean the kind of
music they made was fairly superficial
but like Madonna I mean Madonna but
there's kind of a cleaned up version of
Madonna Madonna showed young girls how
to be sexy
at the same time assertive I think you
know the influence of the Spice Girls
will be band fades it'll go on for
another generation so are you in the
line is anybody contacted a professional
you know just last night in my in my I
was a National Press Club with who I am
I'm in Washington I gave a speech on
women in leadership and I used the
example of a Spice Girls the group
falling falling apart as an example of
the failure of wit of women's knowledge
of teamwork or the way that men are able
to hold together from the Little League
era when I was very young I think that
the inability of girl groups to hang
together for long enough shows a problem
we've got to face say for women to
really break through the glass ceiling
you've got to learn how to be a member
of a team in the workplace or in
Congress do you see women out there who
are successfully being members of team
and therefore successfully getting their
point is I think title 9 even when title
9 has been used excessively is causing
so many men's teams to be to be
disbanded I think the title line over
the long run is going to help women to
learn how to function in teams because
there's a way of subordinating your ego
being competitive in the arena and then
kind of hail-fellow-well-met
back-slapping thing that men have
outside the office okay which glues the
glue that holds together so much of a
corporate network in in the world and
it's something that I think we've got to
start thinking about for girls from the
high school level on this kind of
practical vocational sort of
problem-solving how do you interact in a
group and I just become a diva like this
one Spice Girl immediately well I'm too
big for this I don't have to take this
anymore the great men's groups in rock
have held together over time over
decades even when they fought with each
other you and mate we had fisticuffs
with each other I think we have to
really examine this if women expect to
rise in the world and I want I want a
woman in the White House with an I hope
within a decade who is it I don't I
don't know it's going to be but we
really a queen it's a scandal it's a
scandal that this country where women
are the freest eree we still have not
elected a woman to either vice president
or president what's the story one story
that you've brought with you this
morning that you said to yourself if I
don't get to anything else we've got to
talk about this what is it bilingual
education I'm thrilled but finally that
you
the people of California have woken up
to the reality I have been hammering on
this theme since I came on the scene in
1990 I'm a member of an immigrant family
my mother was born in Italy came here at
the age of six and 1930 and she has the
same position that I do on this question
while all four of my grandparents were
born in Italy thank God there was
nothing no atrocity like bilingual
education when they came here they no
one said to them oh you poor Italian
immigrant you want to preserve your
language your heritage and so we're
going to keep you in this little ghetto
of your own language well it's up to the
family to preserve the language of the
individual in immigrant and it's up to
them to preserve it some of the schools
to do it English is a very difficult
language is now the lingua franca of the
world in the way that French used to be
the language of business and diplomacy
people don't realize how difficult it is
so the kids will pick it up they'll pick
it up from what from the newspapers do
you know there's a complexity of English
spelling of diction it's going to harm a
Hispanic youth okay moving along up the
career track into being a tour attorney
in court there are very subtle uses of
language in English you have got to be
immersed in English from the start to
hear that my parents made a decision
that they would not speaking Italian
even in the home for me I was no
maternal for two or fourteen years and
the reason I'm able to write
best-selling books have gone around the
world realized mastered English as it
was my parents thank God knew that the
master of English was was they was a
door to the world for for immigrant
youth so I'm delighted that finally so
many Latino parents have realized how
their kids have been held back by this
kind of boondoggle it's a boondoggle
phone lines are open if you would like
to talk to Camille Paula this morning
you'll see the phone numbers at the
bottom of your screen you can also email
us or fax us if you would like to do it
in that way and we'll start taking your
calls in just a few minutes you write
for slate
certainly not I write for salon I'm the
parrot or newsman for Salon no no it's
late it is I misspoke yeah that's the
other that is the competitor yes that's
our competitor this is what it looks
like what do you what do you write well
I read a column a bit kind of a advice
column which people were right right in
your email anything from politics to sex
to pop I try to show the full range of
cultural interests I've been going on in
the world today the magazine is based in
San Francisco David Talbott the energy
used to be with the San Francisco
Examiner they have they were early
supporters of my ideas and I think that
these are these men are visionaries and
the salon which is a which is a sort of
way way above Slayton in kind of quality
that's that you know salon it's reach
around the world the kind of messages we
get from Australia or or everywhere from
South Africa to Norway to Chile it's
absolute fantastic one can put something
on the internet at 10 o'clock at night
and the next you know with an hours
being read in London I think it's a
marvelous tool not only people realize
the degree to which the young people are
on the internet I don't think even the
major media realizes the extent to which
their children in the in the
universities in this country are on
hours and hours and hours some some new
international culture is being formed
via the internet which I have great
hopes for in terms of international
understanding and possibly world peace
from a italia has with your book out
we'll be talking about it in this two
hours that she will be with us this
morning
Columbia Maryland you're first up on the
liberal line joining us good morning yes
ma'am miss peg Lee I've listened to you
frequently and enjoyed a lot of what you
said although I don't always agree but
as a lifelong liberal I have a spalling
question I supported affirmative action
for many years I see where it's a
problem or even where I work and across
the country but and perhaps we have to
back off but we need an affirmative
action program sure you will agree what
mechanism can we use other than the
quota system to improve affirmative
action programs well I personally feel
that affirmative action was a noble idea
that was applied in a very brutal and
stupid fashion I think it has ended up
benefiting not the original group for
which was intended African Americans but
white middle-class women who are not in
need of this help I have seen in my view
the way that affirmative action has
distorted the humanities education in
the elite schools across this country
through an enormous number of extremely
mediocre women who have been elevated to
the top rank so I'm talking about the
Ivy League I'm talking about anywhere
from a Harvard to do to Princeton to
Berkeley I think that it's a first of
action has
a part of the general debasement of
intellectual and scholarly standards in
the universities I don't I don't agree
at all with the way the way the quota
tendency of affirmative action no matter
what people say it has been a quota
system I think what we needed to do was
to look at public school education I
want to return to basics that's the way
to help african-american youth make
their way in the world to give them the
basic skills but at the same time as
affirmative action came along this
clumsy government tool we had a complete
abandonment of the inner-city school a
sense that well there's no way to really
have order we can't possibly harm
people's self-esteem by by keeping them
back grade if they haven't mastered
basic skills though there has been
people have to have to have done to
protect themselves in the schools right
now this teachers have lost control of
the classroom there's an administrative
bureaucracy that has drained funds and
an morale from from teachers in the
classroom the the kind of public school
education that I got is that my parents
got coming over my entire immigrant
family got it's quite gone now I think
that's the real affirmative action to
begin at the foundation and not try to
play catch a ball at the top moderate
line Arlington Texas next yes hello I'm
on the line you're on sir camión one of
my heroes even all of a man because of
her views and most things I think that
he thinks out things completely and
absolutely and gives a real honest
opinion but I have one question about
the the magazine you work for and I've
heard it that was created primarily to
support Bill Clinton and you know and
you don't fit that mold and I haven't
read salon magazine but I've heard a lot
of raps that it's primarily a created
for backup support for Clinton well I
actually that is a libel that has been
put out there very recently because of
certain scoops that's a lot and God
about all cotton some weird financial
payoffs that might have been involving
allegedly involving David Hale one of
the primary witnesses and in the Starr
investigation of President Clinton back
in Little Rock
I assure you salon is not in no way a
shell for the for the Clinton White
House these are brilliant journalists so
who the roots are again in the San
Francisco Examiner and we've been
happily going along for two years
publishing an enormous ly wide range of
political and artistic and pop opinion
it's only now that it that the salon has
broken into the news because of this one
one area of its of expose but David
Horowitz like a very prominent
conservative commentator who was once a
radical the nineteen sixties is a
columnist along with me i all though I
am a Clinton democrat originally and
voted for Clinton my my opinion of what
has been going on in the White House has
been blistering and I have so I feel
nuts spared this administration so it is
just a very false wrap I would say
Gaithersburg Maryland your next good
morning Gaithersburg good morning
Camille um I want you to talk about the
mainstream feminist losing their voice
when it comes to Bill Clinton and I also
want to say I love you and I love your
column and thank you for and of feminism
needs to come to the forefront thank you
very much well I have just been in hog
heaven as I have been watching in the
feminist establishment deconstruct to
the past few months it has been
wonderful did you see when I finally
burst on the scene after being silent
for so long unable to to be published in
1990 I began hammering the major media
with the phrase feminist establishment I
have hammered and hammered that and I'm
delighted that finally the media has
woken up and sing what I was talking
about that the problems were not with
feminism they had never been with
feminism they have been with a feminist
establishment and insular coterie a
Politburo a bunch of people of
socialites who who cling together and
who were in what I believe was corrupt
collusion with the hierarchy of the
Democratic Party my own party I have
been delighted with the disarray in the
leading feminist ranks but again it is
quite wrong to say that something has
gone wrong with feminism feminism is
alive and well you said you were
silenced yes
when and how my gosh I'm at a time I was
able to get published when I was 43
years old I had a book that was sexual
persona the book the finally Yale
University Press took a chance on a 700
page book and that that had been
completed nine years before the parts of
book as they were being written
throughout the 1970s I could not get
them published I could not get hired
because I any we're in a major research
university and that continues today it
continues today I am completely
ostracized by the major research
universities in this country it is an
absolute scandal for a person with a
civil hunger page book on the whole
history of the arts from Yale if I'm
invited to speak at a campus it is by
the students or by a small cadre of
dissident faculty you have situations
where you might have people when I went
to for example to give a lecture at
Wellesley College members of the English
department put onto the email of that
universe of that college to the students
don't go to hear her speak here is I'm
like one of the most well known writers
women writers in America right now and
at Wellesley College the faculty will
try to stop the students from coming to
here mistake you cannot believe how bad
it is no one realizes how bad it is in
the major schools in this country they
in the media has been ignoring it but I
believe that they've been trying to
protect the value of the degrees of
their children which they are paying
$30,000 a year for they don't want to
hear this is the bad news that there has
been an absolute disastrous decline in
the teaching of the humanities end of
history as well as in many of the elite
schools another story you're reading
this morning okay well I the religious
freedom bill interests me I'm not sure I
know all of the intricacies of it but I
think that and I'm certainly not I'm not
a conservative at all I am an atheist
but I believe very strongly that
religion needs to be honored much more
in education and in the world because
certainly the kind of philosophy that's
coming out of the schools which is a
kind of nihilistic post-structuralism
which believes there is no truth there
is no meaning in existence that nature
doesn't exist hatred history doesn't
exist
I think that there are kids at the elite
schools who are going to be the the
future leaders of the professions and in
politics and in law and so on that they
have nothing there's a nothingness at
the heart of American culture when
parents haven't given any kind of
spiritual guidance there is no religion
even to rebel against in the home and
then they go to university and our talks
to to to question everything and to end
to adopt oppose a fashionable chic irony
okay about life it's a disaster so I in
general I support this idea that that
there should be a moment in the school
day
which some people may use for silent
prayer others may use for simple
meditation I think that there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that
- to remind people that the universe is
much bigger than the individual self but
you're an atheist I am an atheist that I
respect religion enormous I come out of
a very vibrant Italian Catholic heritage
I believe the great religions of the
world contain an enormous amount of
truth about the meaning of the universe
I in fact I in many of my proposals for
educational reform have I proposed that
that world religions be at the heart of
a true multicultural and global core
curriculum and that ideas you hear
elsewhere now people are repeating it
but that idea when I put it forward 1990
was considered extremely shocking what
you're mentioning religion everyone
knows that that religion is nothing but
oppression and bigotry okay that is
ridiculous inserted in the anti-catholic
kind of bias that you see everywhere in
the major media and in popular culture
and everywhere I think it is abhorrent
is written for extensible on the part of
gay activists or wherever you hear that
that anti-catholic that is another form
of bigotry that the major media is
usually rather silent about congressman
is Turk who is right here in USA Today
this morning it will be with us in about
45 minutes or so actually 35 minutes to
talk about this prayer amendment that's
up before the House today Orlando
Florida you're next with Camille Paul
yes Camille I would rest that you sort
of slowed down your voice you speak so
quickly but some teachers I'm a teacher
I have to wake up to class at 8:30 but
somebody else is ready for change it's
just very difficult to even listen to
you you're very abrasive well lately
you're also very very catty I remember
when you criticize Hillary for taking
too much time off from her duties when
her father died now some of us had
wonderful relationships with our fathers
and when they died it was devastating
you are a cat and you represent as I
immersed in femininity thank you and
slow down listening to you is just very
different when I'm sorry to say that
that kind of over emotional reaction
from Ultimo woman does not do women any
service her contact bet the
her using the word caddy about a woman
intellectual shows what's wrong with
women right now okay
I think that a person who use such a
word is very catty herself I think that
treating Hillary Clinton as if she is
beyond criticism when she had put
herself forward as the head of a massive
health care reform in this country and a
two weeks later suddenly was off tending
to her private business as if she had
had a private life in the way that men
who are in public do not I think that
Hillary Clinton has not done the a
feminist movement any kind of service
she began as the kinds of you're
carrying the banner of contemporary
feminism she is an exact age mate of
mine but I think that Hillary after she
leaves the White House which is going to
recover herself after she gets out from
the shadow of her husband I think that
she will go around the world and be a
very good representative of an
enlightened kind of Western feminism and
speak for the need for women's education
in the world so I think the best of
Hillary may be ahead this email from
Newport Rhode Island I'm still a strong
supporter the president I especially
respect mrs. Clinton and I've heard you
speak positively the positively of them
in the past has your opinion of them
changed well I I am a Clinton democrat
I believe very strongly in Clinton's
original mission to to heal up the grade
schism between liberalism and
conservatism in this country I felt that
these are false polarities that you know
we just need to get rid of them for the
21st century
I've enjoyed is appointed with the
behavior of the Clintons I think that
even though bill is essentially a
populist Erhard coming from a little
rock that they surround themselves with
a kind of arrogant clique of Yale Law
School graduates and I know that very
well having gone to the Yale graduate
school the same time they did they have
the attitude of somehow by a mere IQ
alone that the world can be saved the
kind of brittleness and an in celerity
that I think actually that this is a
process that happened to the Democratic
Party never had a party used to be the
party of working-class people my
grandfather worked in a shoe factory and
the contraction factory was a Franklin
Roosevelt Democrat and slowly over time
the Democratic Party has lost its base
as it did what the Clintons have done
just hung around with the powers-that-be
a kind of very arrogant white
upper-middle class professional cleek
Gainesville
Florida on a moderate line good morning
good morning it's a thrill to speak to
miss Tyler this morning I'm a big fan of
yours Thanks
I wanted to talk to you a little bit
about the what I call the bilingual
establishment because I think that there
is such a thing and they're very
involved in ethnic politics mm-hmm I
myself I was born in Cuba and my family
came to this country when I was one
month old I learned to speak Spanish in
the home I did not speak a word of
English and I was sent to kindergarten
without speaking English and the teacher
sent me home until my mother well at
this time kindergarten was not mandatory
and they said she has to return for
first grade perhaps she can speak
English a little better and then that
one year I picked up English very well
and I believe that I flourished as a
student I'm now a PhD candidate at a
major research university and this is
just something that I think that it's so
important and it's people missed the
mark a lot but you know about the
changeover how immersion is so important
and secondly my I feel that I have a
very good identity my family preserve
that for me I agree with you it's not
the government mission to preserve the
identity of any all ethnic backgrounds
of children particularly with Hispanics
I believe there is a very large
establishment there I don't know who has
something to do with teachers unions or
perhaps preserving an identity for our
Democratic base as you mentioned before
the Democratic base dissolving but I
have a suggestion for bilingual teachers
I wanted to see what you thought about
this in California since bilingual
education is going to be going away
pretty soon how would you feel about the
teachers instead teaching all students a
second language that's something I think
this country is really missed the mark
on words in Europe and Asia most
students eat two maybe even three
languages sort of things oh I so agree
with that that is one thing we
desperately need in an education is the
kids should be taught languages early
early on in fact I think that's an
excellent way to train the mind you
become more aware of your own language
by studying a foreign languages I was
trained in Latin in high school and so
many Latin programs have been abandoned
my whole sense of the etymology of words
and how the structure sentences come so
much from from from Latin I think we
really need to do this the the
provincialism the parochialism of
American culture it is also an area
where the major media can help
my mother years ago her irritation every
time the Pope opens his mouth speaking
in foreign language from from the
balcony st. Peter's all of a sudden you
get you get another voice coming in you
know the voice of the announcer heaven
forbid you should ever hear someone
speaking a foreign language my mother
call to say that the Pope said awk the
public goes off like that and then
immediately cut off terminated I think
that if someone speaking in a foreign
language it should be subtitled on
screen or something like that it is
really terrible what we're doing to our
young people making them feel like
America somehow is if it's like a planet
moving around the solar system
independent from all the other cultures
and languages of the world Van Buren
Arkansas on the liberal line good
morning good morning miss Polya and on
the article that she wrote about Monica
Lewinsky being a little pudgy that bless
you it was good to see some fluffy women
coming to the forefront it was a
wonderful wonderful piece but I have a
couple of questions I have she reminds
me of my best friend of 30 years who is
remained pretty snarly and and I I was
pretty snarly and I want to execute my
best friend has never married in the 30
years and I had children I think that
marrying and having children took a
white quite a bit of Mike's gnarliness
30 years what but then I've gotten it
back recently I wonder do I see doubt
about this about what a motherhood makes
you become listen early I don't know I
think you saw I think my mother would
definitely certainly takes the edges off
Oh egotism how often I have seen of
famous actresses after they become
pregnant suddenly being interviewed on
Entertainment Tonight and saying I
almost as if they become Stepford Wives
in certain ways they go I now realize
I'm not important my child is important
I'm concerned about the future I think
there is something in the in the
biological transformation of pregnancy
in childbirth that that does put one
one's own vocational interests on the
shelf as you as you you look forward
toward posterity I think gives women a
kind of historical perspective through
pregnancy for those who didn't read it
what did you write about Monica Lewinsky
being touched oh well a number a number
of things over the ball I her kind of
her full fleshy Roux benzion quality
I think it's a positive it appeared
where we're a little bit too concerned
about you know about fitness to so many
of the styles and the magazines are
indeed geared to a kinds of Carolyn
Bessette since a rail kind of physique I
think it's about time that distorts
indeed are started to think more clearly
about the need to have a more full
figured Fashion I think I think it's
part of a movement but in general though
if women seem to be a war with their own
bodies estrogen the you know the female
hormone puts fat deposits on all the
curvy places that other sexual men
esteem women for and so in a culture
that we're where the the very thin look
is a kind of boyish athletic look is is
idealized you have women involved in for
all of the lives forty years of the
lives evolved in what is essentially a
battle with nature I want to ask you
then about the front-page story in The
Washington Post this morning where the
federal government is expected to
announce soon that there's plans to
change its definition of what is a
healthy weight it's a controversial move
that's going to change the
classification of an estimated twenty
nine million Americans who are now
considered normal weight and they will
be redefined as overweight so what the
cutoff point in hello where will be
lowered but it's also a different kind
of they do a statistical analysis where
they look at different factors but yeah
basically here's here's the chart right
here if people of these weights
we're considered healthy by federal
degree they will now be overweight for
instance of five foot two person at 136
pounds will be considered overweight now
hi I'm coming out of Italian culture
where you know an extra weights instead
of healthy and I think that there's
something may be wrong with this I I'm a
little physicians I teach a course
called women in sex roles at the
University of the Arts and we one of the
main themes of this course is to trace
the the oscillating vision of women
through history from the the early very
voluptuous Great Goddess statuettes
where were the large breasts and
buttocks are a symbol of affluence and
the fertility of nature to the to the
center almost anorectic look of the
periods in which actually women take a
place in society
it's a theme that goes back and forth if
we just compare the ideal woman of the
1890s for example with her overflowing
bosom mentor and her accentuated hips we
would have a bustle on the back of a of
the dress a very large voluminous skirts
making her look like a kind of queen bee
compare that to the 1920s the flapper
look after a world war one of the kind
of androgynous look where the breasts
were flattened and so on and so if you
happen to be lucky enough to have your
body conform to the prevailing
stereotype you you know you're very
popular is 10 years later you could you
could have lost the Sweepstakes of
popularity so it's so it's not something
I don't believe it's something that's
being imposed by men I don't think it's
like a sexist conspiracy to give women
low self-esteem or anything like that I
think it has to do with the weather
whether people are living in
agricultural time where we're of
survival is necessary therefore the at
the plump woman is a sign of FOSS parity
and health or you're in a time when
women are expected to be more like men
and to make their way in the world by
brain and by the weather fit whether
their talents or vocational talents but
we're in a period right now
unfortunately which in which the proper
look is a bit too thin for my taste
Alexandria Virginia conservative line
good morning good morning first of all I
say thank you for c-span I can't tell
you how much I appreciate it and that
what a joy it is to talk to you Camille
I certainly don't agree with you
politically a lot of issues but you
exude such an honesty about your opinion
that it's a pleasure to listen to you
whenever I can on c-span thank you I'd
like your opinion on two things if I may
we've raised seven daughters and they
all went to a private all-girls school
and my feeling is that it's because of
that they have become such strong
independent women I think they were
active in sports and things like that
and I for years I've been saying what
you said about women not being able to
be a team player and it's because they
never had that opportunity I'd like your
opinion on that and the fact that it I
find it very difficult issues with women
because they seem to take it every issue
very personally and you seem to be able
to
discuss any issue at all and not have
that personal emotional and on it right
yes I think this is a terrible problem
that women do over personalized
political and intellectual issues but
what you said about the all-girl
education my sister went to Smith
College for example and there are there
are positives and negatives to any such
experience obviously being separate from
men as you're being trained is unnatural
because women will have to interact with
men in the workplace on the other hand
being with all girls for a while I think
does help to strengthen women women's
ability to speak and to present
themselves I don't agree with it there's
our there's another one of these
boondoggle industries out there talking
about the wooden girls low self-esteem
and in early adolescence the way that
teachers are discriminate against girls
in the classroom and pay more attention
to boys that is such a bunch of malarkey
wherever you hear that deficit nonsense
the real fact of the matter is the
missing term in all these discussions is
that women young girls suddenly
experience their first periods they
suddenly undergo that the menstrual
process is enormous thing that happens
to them from inside their bodies and all
of a sudden they become quieter and more
reflective it's an enormous and profound
experience I think it's an embarrassment
factor that women don't want to
embarrass them so I can see it as a
teacher of 27 years in the classroom
that you can see the girls who are very
excellent students and they're very
attentive they're usually far better
than the boys as the rare bore this as
good as the girls but I can see in their
eyes don't embarrass me don't call me
don't let me make a fool of myself where
the boys don't care all right the boys
are immature they're mad egotist they
don't care if they make a fool of
themselves they just want to express
themselves right that's what I see is
that this is why the the endless of
self-esteem are so totally wrong when
the teachers are paying more attention
on the boys and say shut up put your
feet down you're being a fool all that
sort thing and the boys love it they
love attention for its own sake so I do
think that that all-girls schools in
fact all-boys schools in in high school
as well by removing the sexual
attraction issue okay from the dynamic I
think it does allow both sexes to
develop their vocational skills Tucson
Arizona on the moderate line good
morning oh hi miss peg lamp is very nice
stuck to you
are you aware of the following that you
have among gay people you know we have
gay friends in Mexico event and thanks
to the web we've been able to share your
writings and and stuff and the other
part of my question is are you aware
that you're always questioning
establishment even gay establishment and
NRI are you doing that on purpose yes I
am ok fine I'm an open lesbian of by
sexual experience and I have been open
warfare with the gay activist
establishment in this country I have to
say I have I have yet to meet a gay
activist that I would trust you know
across the street with my you know with
with my wallet I think they have some of
the most vicious dishonest people I have
ever encountered in my life there what
could they have eyes that are cold
absolutely cold it is impossible to have
any kinds of dialogue with them I mean
everywhere I've gone to try to open up
any kind of discussion with them it has
not succeeded and at this point in
America thank heavens they've they've
lost the kind of cachet that they once
had the major media however is still
very much manipulated from behind the
scenes I think by gay activists pressure
I'm not happy with their whole issues
for example about the origins of
homosexuality that are that are awful
you know they're verboten no one can
dare to come near them there's only one
way of looking at homosexuality in terms
of oppressors and victims this kind of
sentimental scenario of history that gay
people have been imprisoned throughout
history and now finally they're finding
their true place and it's up to everyone
to let me well there are no questions
being asked about the relationship of
homosexuality to the to the family unit
to all kinds of cultural pressures that
are going on the ICC I'm obviously
entirely 100% in favor of gay rights I'm
a libertarian I believe the government
has no right to tell you what you do in
your private life or in your bedroom I
get the government powers it can stop I
act as your own private door on the
other hand I believe that the kind of
strident claims that homosexuality is
equal to heterosexuality and that and
that you're or you're born gay invented
it's not a choice sorting on
and that people who are attempting to
help other gay men let's say to be able
to relate heterosexually to a woman that
said that such things are homophobic and
that have to have to be stopped and
there's all kinds of harassment of
therapy groups where we're perfectly
voluntary discussions are going on
on the part of gay people who feel that
their lifestyle is no longer as
satisfying as they would want it to be
so I'm just try try to just just try to
break through into every possible closed
area of discourse and I am aware of my
international fans that I have in the
Latin American world I give my ideas for
example are exactly like those of Brazil
I mean my attitudes toward life are very
much Mediterranean and there's a lot of
Mediterranean of course immigration into
Brazil so I think I'm more understood
perhaps outside the borders of the
United States Toms River New Jersey I'm
liberal in the morning I guess this guy
clea you were speaking about models that
have been they are do you seem to be
tested that role that you're so thin
yourself I'm wondering if you if you get
that way by your constant talking you
can see when you're talking and your
disposition and your you're so volatile
but if you ever read and read yes
unfortunately I do need slid I
well actually I'm constantly battling
the boss I am adored and eating I may
have Pearson but it's a constant battle
being Italian I eat enormous quantities
of food so it's I'm not naturally said
no my father certainly was i I never
even though I'm criticizing the tendency
of models to be a little bit too thin in
the magazine's right now I am a great
supporter of the fashion industry and of
the fashion magazines and I think one of
the services I have done in feminism in
the 1990s was to get people off that
ridiculous rhetoric that the fashion
magazines are there to give women low
self-esteem and so on I see the fashion
magazines many of which have gay artists
operating in photography in makeup in
costume ISM I see the fashion magazines
as artworks for the masses and most
people most ordinary housewives like to
least through fashion magazines they
don't get a low self-esteem from doing
it they love to simply glory in the
beauty and the color of these
magnificent tech tutorials which are
available for free 95 on the newsstand
so I don't want to seem to be part of
the the feminist group is constantly
demean fashion magazines your three
books sexual persona in 1990 what was
that about again well persona is a an
account of the whole history of images
of sexuality from kvar through ancient
Egypt ancient Greece to the Renaissance
down to the 19th century which I deal
with a lot of major authors adapted 1900
in the second volume of sexual
facilities on popular culture I'm
currently revising that and sex art in
American culture 1992 isn't the
collection of my essays with a number of
other new essays I wrote on the subject
of sex in art and culture 1994 vamps and
[ __ ] and again more more of my
collected essays and all kinds of other
things cartoons that have been done
about me and so on and this one sold the
best well sexual persona is is the
best-selling work of literary criticism
of the 1990s you never know from the
attitude of the Ivy League it was a
breakout book that is it was simply a
book published by a University Press
about any kind of publicity my pressure
my picture wasn't on I was unknown and
for some mysterious reason the book kept
selling and selling and selling and has
gone around the world in many languages
and it shows that people are very hungry
right now for for looking at literature
and art in terms of appreciation and
respect and honor and not trashing
literature and are in the way that is
taught you in the Ivy League in all the
schools the elite schools right now
they're questioning going with a red pen
through the great works in going fast oh
racism sexism homophobia like that I'm
Italian and I was trained to it to honor
the artist and to honor great our I
believe art contains the whole history
of humanity and so I think people were
eager for that written in plain English
people you know work to me general
readers are writing to me about this is
the best that you know education I have
had since I've gone to the library and
taking so many books out you stimulate
the desire to read and to study so I
mean I I feel that I've made a
connection with the general audience
which is indeed
thirsty for for you know for the history
of art in fact that leads us into one of
the other things I chose this morning
which is a magnificent full-page ad
in the New York Times for a new
exhibition at the Metropolitan Museum
our Edward burne-jones a one of my
favorite painters he actually there are
certain illustrations from him in my
book sexual persona look at magnificent
full-page ad now there you have the
people whatever a major exhibition is
offered now on Cezanne or any major
artist people at palak utterly flock
right this is the kind of you know in
education that they're no longer getting
in the universities the universities are
into all the artists and it relieves
this are is merely a tool of a political
agenda but here we have the museum's now
offering themselves as shrines of
culture I absolutely support it I think
this is a full-color ad coming at one in
the envy you know black and white New
York Times it's just magnificent I
believe that art is the record again of
the highest impulses in humanity if
we're going to represent ourselves so
just in civilizations around the
galaxies if they exist we will show
ourselves by our art and so I feel that
the attitude of the major academic
establishment or art is utterly
reprehensible utterly utterly
reprehensible it is shameful shameful
okay the kind of skepticism okay and
kind of oppose the superiority that our
best students are being tutored in we'll
talk about your new book after this call
from ELF is it Alpharetta Georgia
Alpharetta Georgia where is that it's a
in Newt Gingrich district north of
Atlanta thanks for joining us on the
conservative line your earlier actually
that's only mine I could get in on I am
a libertarian like you miss Polly I'm
surprised I was a first of all let me
say god bless you thank you I was quite
disappointed with the Republican Party
but I wanted to talk about three women
real quickly if I could in my life first
one is my wife she comes from South
Korea
I'm not 33 years old right now she's 30
she came over here didn't speak a word
of English and the only reason she
wasn't valedictorian of her high school
class and she was came over here in our
sophomore year is because she wasn't
here long enough okay she learned it on
her own watching Sesame Street second
woman I like to talk about is my mother
my mother worked
all the time and she raised four kids
okay she still wants to this day her she
makes more money than any of her kids to
this day okay so I don't understand a
lot of the uproar about women working
having to go into the into the work and
another woman I like to talk about is my
sister who's probably the toughest woman
I've ever known
I mean she's divorced now is raising two
kids but I never once heard her cry and
say oh mighty federal government helped
me and I just think your breasts the
fresh air and I had a different opinion
LP but I'm glad to see you this morning
well thank you very much yes I think of
an attitude of my family coming over
middle II and working extremely hard
Italians have the attitude about the
labor working working working my you
know my grandfather worked all you know
all day long at the at the shoe factory
my grandmother's work constantly working
in the home and there is a kind of ethic
of of labor of work and not looking
against it Hannah
on the other hand the Endicott Johnson
the shoe factory was running in very
enlightened way by by the man who
founded it and he had provided health
care to his workers and boxcars of
citrus fruit would arrive from his
Florida home every winter for the people
he allowed he had plans to allow the the
shoe leather workers to to build homes
of their own which my grandfather was
able to do so I think there's a great
regular row room for an enlightened kind
of capitalism I'm a capitalist I believe
very strongly that the Industrial
Revolution has allowed women to emerge
strongly into independent and
self-sufficient economic life in the
modern world I don't see capitalism as
the enemy on the other hand I do think
we need to have just our teaching ethics
to our aspiring businessmen so that they
you know that they will have a feeling
for their workers which certainly is not
part of the of the president of the
two-tiered system of lavish perks at the
top and and rather low pay scale at the
bottom america's first look at the cover
of your new book what is it
the Burroughs Alfred Hitchcock's the
birds one of his great classic films the
British Film Institute asked me to write
on on the film I chose this one and it
will be out in
months in London it is a from beginning
to end of the film I tried to explain
every single detail of its production
and interpretation and commentary of the
performances and and so I just went by
this movie this movie is about nature
it's about the enormous power of nature
and how and that's another one of the
subjects which is denied in the elite
schools right now nature doesn't exist
to them you know we're born tabula rasa
were born blank slates we become male
and female later a nature of something
another I think that nature is an
overwhelming force it's my religion it's
my religion like sense of the vastness
of the universe of geology - my favorite
science the ferocity of the birds coming
in it reflects the fact that we still
have not solved the mystery of man's
place in the universe Paris Texas you're
next on the moderate line good morning
good morning Camille I'm a huge fan I'm
so excited to talk to you - thank you
I love sexual personae it really
illuminated a lot for me ever since I've
read it thank you very much I was
excited to hear that you consider
yourself a libertarian and I wondered if
you have ever considered any kind of
political office I think you would be
such a wonderful candidate to give
legitimacy to libertarianism
well the libertarian party is now and
then written to me and asked me if I
would be interested in it possibly used
to being the presidential candidate I am
NOT material I'm afraid for politics I'm
an intellectual I'm a teacher I'm used
to like my entire manner comes from 27
years of managing kids in the classroom
and so on I you need voices like mine
outside the system I think we're just
kind of whistleblowers and we're there
just to make a lot of trouble I think
that a politician need far greater
diplomatic skills and I have I'm afraid
I don't suffer fools gladly
and you have to just have a kind of
equanimity of temper that I think I lack
but I do think that aspiring women
politicians need to learn you mentioned
you went to Yale well I went to the
State University of New York at
Binghamton and for my undergraduate
degree we had a superb education in this
public school then I went to Yale
University for my PhD and was there at
the same time as the Clintons were
across the street at the Law School
posted English in English was my patient
yes that's correct and but but you know
my my general interest is in the history
of the arts and culture you grew up in
Endicott
New York I was born Endicott New York
that's right and then we moved to a
small town called Oxford and lived in a
farm for bit and then we were in
Syracuse my father was first a high
school teacher and then a a college
teacher and after I'm a product of
Snowbell I think that women who grow up
in the snow belt whether we're talking
about Wisconsin or upstate New York tend
to have a kind of feisty forthright
manner because we're so used to dealing
with the elements when you were young
who was the person that you look to as
someone who inspired you or was your
role model well early on my father
taught me early on to think for myself
there was up there I was saying at the
National Press Club last night that my
father taught me how to put up my hands
and to fight like a boy essentially when
I was young not to allow myself to be
pushed around on the street to be ready
to defend myself and my you know my
father wanted me to the chart
independent path okay it my mother
wanted me to you know to they have an
eye for for for social proprieties too
and so I think I had I had a good
balance of the way I was I was raised I
have very powerful personalities in my
Italian background very powerful women
and powerful men so I come from this
tradition of outspoken people
charismatic men and and you're powerful
women and therefore I'm very impatient
with the kind of mealy-mouthed you know
the nerdiness that I see among the
students when I go to the elite school
may all of the feminist rhetoric that
the women are being taught in the elite
schools certainly not making them as
powerful as my grandmother was for
example my mom my grandma that kind of
majesty an awesome power I don't see
anywhere in these in these little whiny
little girls that are being produced by
contemporary feminism are your parents
still alive my father died in the early
1990s and my mother still lives in
Syracuse what does she think of your
success well my sister said to my mother
at one point she said just imagine how
Mick Jagger's mother must have felt
while my mother is not crazy about
publicity but I think that you know she
she agrees with a lot of my positions
obviously like about bilingual education
and and so on so you know I think I'm
carrying the Italian American flag
Serleena we've had Italian Americans a
lot in the education industry like Frank
Sinatra and so on but really not that
many those gay talese and so on who have
risen in in the world of scholarship or
especially my italian-american women so
I'm glad to be pushing forward there
Washington DC on the liberal line good
morning good morning um I just want come
in for wonderful job you're doing I
think you're a pioneer for women around
the world hope to keep up the good work
oh thank you thank you very much
Springfield Virginia you're next good
morning Springfield good morning am I on
yes you are Camille my name is Ralph I'm
an italian-american and you're my
favorite liberal I love your column I
read the salon on the Internet are you
familiar with the graduation speech it
was made by the New York Times city
editor I believe it was at Barnard
College no apparently the article I read
it was sort of a slip of the tongue is
the way they pitched it but she talked
about how she gave up family to devote
full time to her career and the tenor of
the article was that this is what men do
all the time they devote 100% of their
time if they want to get to the top of
their career and I'd like to get your
comments I'll hang up now and put the
television back on so I pull attention
to you thank you well it really is true
that over time that men have given an
enormous amount of their of their lives
to providing a livelihood for their
families I think that that is one of the
the raw deals that men have gotten an
infamous rhetoric of the last of the
last 25 years I think that you know that
there's a war in Pharaoh's book the myth
of male power talks about this men the
idea that somehow men are just enough of
themselves working those very very long
days and it's costing emotionally at
home being so distant from from the
family unit I suddenly have an example
in italian-american culture is that you
know men being extremely devoted to
family life I didn't have experience of
any negligent or abusive men in my whole
family history so I feel that you know
the kind of rhetoric I'm not sure which
which
figure it from the New York Times you're
talking about here but it's all off a
lot let's say of garbage that comes out
of the hierarchy of the New York Times I
mean say it the near times used to be a
magnificent newspaper the 1970s and like
an ass kissably alone reads in it half
the time these days I'm even I'm writing
for myself I'm very discouraged by that
by the quality of journalism and the
quality of thinking of most of the
northeastern newspapers male Palio will
be rejoining us in about 15 minutes and
we will continue to go through some of
the papers the story that she's read
we're going to give you a break however
you can get a cup of coffee and read
some of the papers at in our green room
in the meantime we're going to talk to
congressman is took from Oklahoma who is
joining us congressman is took is the
leader of the movement and the writer of
the amendment that will be up on the
House floor this morning good morning
congressman well good morning I want to
ask you about this front-page piece in
this morning's Washington Times with the
headline the GOP prayers amendment will
heal the rift with the right it Reba
Ginn's by saying Republican leaders in
Congress will move today to heal a rift
with their conservative supporters do
you think that your amendment would do
that the purpose of the amendment is not
to heal a rift with any particular group
the purpose of the amendment is for
Congress to start responding to what the
American people have felt since 1962
when the Supreme Court began these
outlandish decisions using the First
Amendment not to protect religious
rights but to restrict freedom starting
with the sixty-two Amendment saying that
even if it was voluntary during the
school day during school hours kids
couldn't come together and pray booze
followed with the 1980 decision saying
the Ten Commandments could not be put on
the wall of a public school
the 1985 decision where it said even a
law to permit a moment of silence was
unconstitutional because it permitted
silent prayer then there was the 1992
decision saying that a prayer offered to
the school graduation was also
unconstitutional so the purpose of this
amendment is to have Congress finally
start addressing these Supreme Court
decisions many of them were 5-4
decisions close calls with the Supreme
Court Congress has the ability to do
something but we haven't had a vote on
the necessary constitutional amendment
since 1971 that's the reason that this
is coming up today this is an amendment
to what this is an amendment to the
Constitution to specify that even though
we will never have an official
government religion government
established religion nevertheless the
people's right to pray on public
property including schools and to
recognize their religious traditions
heritage or beliefs shall not be
infringed so it has both the protection
as the First Amendment properly states
it to make sure that we don't have any
official church but it corrects how the
Supreme Court has twisted and warped the
First Amendment First Amendment is a
beautiful piece of work and what the
Founding Fathers intended for to mean is
really proper but the Supreme Court
began to twist it began to distort it
and rather than using it to protect
religious freedom they have used it to
attack religion in the country so at the
same time as we have guns coming into
school knives coming into school drugs
coming into school and yet some people
say what they want to make sure that
they keep out is prayer that's just not
right we're opening up our phone lines
invite you to join us with congressmen
news took this morning he'll be with us
for about 15 minutes to take your calls
there's the numbers at the bottom of
your screen two oh two six two four
eleven eleven if you're a liberal two oh
two six two four eleven fifteen if
you're conservative and 202 seven
thirty-seven six seven thirty four if
you're a moderate congressman I'm
frantically looking here in the papers
today because I wanted to be able to
read the exact wording of it you
wouldn't happen to have the wording of
your amendment with you with you someone
here it's just off camera behind me my
packet I'll pull out okay make sure that
I don't miss quoted from you know yeah
it's in a couple papers and this morning
I just thought it might be helpful while
you're doing that let me go ahead and
ask you about this this is today's USA
Today lead editorial against your
Amendment this morning they write this
but far from protecting religious
freedom it could deprive religious
minorities in any community of the
protections written by the founding
fathers further it would open the public
till to taxpayer subsidies for religious
institutions well but that's that's
incorrect on both counts
I think what some people unfortunately
have done is to say well the
Constitution is meant to protect me from
religion and that means that if in some
gathering in a public place if even one
person objects and says well I'm
thin-skinned I'm intolerant I don't want
to hear somebody else's prayer then that
means they are enabled to censor
everybody else that's an attack not only
on religious freedom that's an attack on
free speech secondly when it comes to
the portion of the amendment that deals
with benefits this is not funding of
religious activity this is simply saying
that faith-based groups such as drug
treatment programs and so forth have the
same right to participate in federal
grants to help further those objectives
as anything else we already have for
example over a billion dollars a year in
federal social service grants that goes
to Catholic Charities USA there's
nothing new about this what we are
trying to do is to protect certain
Supreme Court decisions the Supreme
Court has waffled in this area of
whether a religious organization for a
secular purpose can receive federal
dollars most recently they have come
down on the side of saying yes it's okay
and before they change their mind again
we simply want to lock in those
decisions that's what that's about let's
look at the language of the religious
freedom amendment and this is what the
house will vote on later today and it
reads as follows to secure the people's
right to acknowledge God according to
the dictates of conscience neither the
United States nor any state shall
establish any official religion but the
people's right to pray and to recognize
their religious beliefs heritage or
traditions on public property including
schools shall not be infringed neither
the United States nor any state shall
require any person to join in prayer or
other religious activity prescribed
school prayers discriminate against
religion or deny equal access to a
benefit on account of religion did you
did you come up with the wording the the
wording is the combination of years of
efforts by multiple people obviously on
the principle sponsor of the bill it was
amended also within the Judiciary
Committee and as you probably noticed
reading it we've gone to pains not only
to make sure that people are guaranteed
that their religious rights don't stop
when they step onto public property but
to also make clear with there's no
official government sanctioned religion
to be established
nobody has ever compelled to
join in saying a prayer or for that
matter any other religious activity so
we've got the safeguards and also it
says any prayer in school cannot be a
government composed prayer nor can
government insist that it must take
place the standard I think let me just
if I make this simple point the standard
is the same as the Supreme Court has
established for the Pledge of Allegiance
the Supreme Court has ruled that no
child can be compelled to say the Pledge
of Allegiance but they did not give
someone who didn't want to say it the
right to censor everybody else who did
want to say it phone calls for you
congressman valparaiso indiana on the
conservative line your first step good
morning yes I would just like to say
that I think we should hold us you know
our Supreme Court justice accountable
versus jumping up and one demented
Constitution every time elected official
thinks that you know this is going to be
popular right now when will it stop
playing with the Constitution you know
start holding people accountable for
their actions we've been trying to do
that since 1962 when they made this
ruling unfortunately the efforts to try
to get the Supreme Court to change these
decisions even though as I said several
of them were 5-4 decisions have been
unsuccessful so are we going to go
another generation without having this
fixed or we're going to use the
mechanisms the founding fathers gave us
within the Constitution to correct these
things namely through a constitutional
amendment it's the only route that's
left often you're next on the liberal
line morning Boston yeah hi morning I
have a problem with the idea of forcing
someone I know you're saying that it's
not forcing that's right absolutely not
forcing anyone well you're saying that
it's okay to subject someone to have to
sit there in school and listen to
someone else right well let's address
that issue right now the law says that
kids are required to be in school and
one of the Supreme Court justices who
dissented from this told people what the
so called captive audience really is he
says for children to be required to
spend all day in school and not have
what is normal everyplace else for
example here in Congress we open
sessions with prayer legislators open
sessions with prayer City Council
meetings open with prayer chamber of
commerce meetings open with prayer so as
Justice Stewart said
his dissent to require kids to be at
school and there to say they have to be
isolated from what is normal within
society is not neutrality toward
religion what he said it is is placing
religion and an artificial state created
disadvantaged neutrality as he said in
the dissent consists of saying if
somebody wants to be able to pray that
ought to be equally protected just as
any other right of free speech Arlington
Virginia you're next on the moderate
line good morning I yeah I had a
questions the representative I'm Trish
you know how this amendment would
protect the religious freedom of those
citizens whose religion does not
acknowledge a guide with a capital G
well you know this amendment protects
everyone whether it's minority majority
whether you believe in God who don't
believe in God because we state clearly
that it's according to the dictates of
individual conscience we state clearly
that neither the United States nor any
state shall ever establish any official
religion we state clearly that no person
is ever compelled to participate and
join in a prayer nor ever compelled to
engage in any other religious activity
the government shall not compose prayers
for people nor insist that prayers must
occur so we have plenty of safeguards in
the amendment we've tried to be
sensitive to everyone but for goodness
sakes we want to get away from the
notion of saying that just because a
couple of people may disagree therefore
they can stop out the rights of the vast
majority of people who believe that
prayer is positive and uplifting and
something that we need not only in
everyday life but ours our students need
to be exposed to it too from the
conservative line Washington DC hi I
want to say that these kinds of bills
and things that come up and they're
issued all the time as a representative
just cost a lot of money and I think
that this is a push to restrain other
people's religions I'm a conservative
but at the same time I'm both African
American and Jewish and I see the
problem when you are forced to sit
somewhere and observe something that
you're not really a part of the
restraints that my children are forced
to be in school and for them to have to
be there and sit next to Christians
they're out for Christmas they're out
for
I have to take my children out for our
religious holidays I'm just I just think
these whole kind of bills I think these
things should be left alone I just hope
these kinds of bills are squashed and
this won't pass thank what you're
actually arguing against I think is the
very notion of public schools because
because public schools already require
your children to do all sorts of things
with which you may not agree or disagree
and the point here is are you tolerant
of those other things
which go on in public schools into which
your child is objected I might mention
you mentioned you're both African
American and Jewish one of the groups
that supports this is the National
Conference of Jews and blacks we also
have the largest black denomination in
the country the National Baptist or
among them the great many denominations
and groups supporting it we have other
other members of the Jewish faith such
as a national Jewish organization of
rabbis called toward tradition so this
is not by any means an exclusively
Christian effort this email came coming
in this morning for you congressman
why even under today's Constitution
can't I go to school and pray to myself
to my own personal God religion is
personal why do I have to involve anyone
else in a public display there they're
there multiple types of prayer whether
you're talking about in the Bible or
elsewhere people pray singly and they
also pray in groups it's important the
people have the freedom to do it both
ways I mentioned that a number of these
court decisions were five to four ruling
if you read for example the ruling where
the Supreme Court said that a prayer
offer to the school graduation was
unconstitutional you will find that
justices Rehnquist Scalia Thomas and
white said in their dissent what the
rest of the Court did that nothing
brings people together nothing helps
them develop not only a toleration but
actually an affection for people of
other faiths then coming together to
pray together but that is uniting force
not a divisive force what's your own
religious background congressman my own
religious background I I was raised in
Texas I was raised as a Southern Baptist
on the convert to the Church of Jesus
Christ of latter-day saints often called
Mormon oh and certainly you know in my
lifetime I have visited many people and
other faiths had all sorts of
discussions and I enjoy the opportunity
to be around people of different faiths
and further that understanding was there
ever a time in which you were not
allowed to pray in a public school or
felt that you couldn't I grew up during
the time when the school prayer was
either allowed or when the civil
disobedience which still exists today
and some people think because they
haven't been sued yet that therefore
they're safe from a lawsuit there's a
lot of civil disobedience with prayers
in schools today and I grew up in a time
when we had prayer in public school and
even after the Supreme Court ruling
where they hadn't gotten around to suing
our locality and other localities yet so
I grew up as part of this tradition we
had prayer the start of the school day
we had prayer at my high school
graduation both of the start or ended
the finish of it and people felt free to
have not at Christmas time at school
programs not only to sing something
likes prosti the snowman but be able to
sing oh come all ye faithful or silent
night nowadays even the post office has
taken down the banners which used to say
Merry Christmas and Happy Hanukkah and
there's plenty of other examples we can
cite where there's an effort
unfortunately oh
supposedly to comply with the
Constitution to sanitize religion from
public life and when people are
concerned about what's going on in
school and they say you know we need to
be able to talk about values nothing
nothing brings values along with it more
than exposure to the devotional positive
experiences of prayer after all as I
said before we have too many guns and
knives and metal detectors and drugs and
teenage pregnancies in our public
schools and many many people say you
know it would be nice if with all those
other things we were able to have a
little bit of prayer - a couple more
calls for you New Haven Connecticut on
the liberal line good morning good
morning good morning I am a lifelong
very devout Christian and a minister for
some 30 years and I want to urge
Christians not to be fooled by people
like history and the Christian Coalition
who are simply a friend for the
Republican Party trying to seduce as
many Christians as possible to come over
to the Republican Party and this
district amendment like his prior istic
amendment which was a crazy plan to
limit people's expression in
and organizations know and a crazy idea
of reforming which was d-forming public
financing this idea as well is a bad
idea
it reflects the old mentality of Europe
where religion and politics were totally
in this wind and the churches influenced
the government and a government
influenced religion well I think someone
has certainly given the gentleman a is
some sort of twisted version of what
I've done and also if you want to talk
about the origin of this you look at the
public opinion polls and I've got a
collection of dozens of public opinion
polls which date back to the Supreme
Court decision of 1962 you will find
consistently 75 to 80% of the American
people not only support school prayer
but support a constitutional amendment
to make it possible to have school
prayer not compulsory but voluntary once
again on a freely permitted basis in our
public schools so for the gentleman to
think that this is some sort of
conspiracy he needs to look at 75 to 80
percent of the American people who have
supported this for the last 36 years
moderate line Elkin West Virginia what
is to have a couple question what is
what has taken so long to get the
Freedom Act back mmm-hmm I think that's
a good question we have not had a vote
on a school prayer member in the House
of Representatives since 1971 and that
vote happened despite the efforts of the
then majority to block it it was brought
up through what they call the discharge
petition process and this has not been
on the agenda of Congress and that's why
the the issue has been let go since 1971
because the the people that were in
leadership in Congress blocked efforts
to bring this up to a vote it's only
when the majority of Congress changed in
1994 that it became possible to pursue
this actively with the expectation that
we would in fact be able to get a vote
and that vote will happen today
congressman as for our viewers who are
watching the House of Representatives
later today give us a little idea of
what they will see and when they might
see it okay this bill should be brought
up sometime before noon when we begin
consideration for those that know the
process of the house there will be an
hour debate on the rule
there will be two hours of general
debate and then there'll be an hour
debate on an amendment that will be
offered to this legislation so obviously
people will hear both sides developed
what I understand happens quite freely
is there's a lot of scare tactics the
different people employ on something
like this and that's really unfortunate
but I think that as I've mentioned
before some people want to say oh my
goodness who who would believe in such a
thing and I'll tell them many many
justices of the US Supreme Court have
dissented and said that the court has
gone in the wrong direction in this
whole series of decisions one of those
is the Chief Justice of the United
States Supreme Court William Rehnquist
who has led the dissent from what a a
bare slim majority of the justices have
done in many cases and as I said before
that's where Congress has an obligation
to step in when the Supreme Court takes
the Constitution that's intended to
protect religious freedom and begins to
use it as a weapon to suppress and
silence a lot of religious expression
Congress has a duty to step in and to
try to do something about it the
Constitution is meant to make sure we
don't have any sort of official
government dictated faith but a prayer
is not establishing a government Church
it's merely establishing an opportunity
for free exercise of religion
Congressman Ernest Istook is a
Republican of Oklahoma elected in 1992
he represents the fifth District which
is where congressman it's principally
around Oklahoma City although goes to
other parts of the state too thanks very
much for joining it extra morning we'll
be checking in at beginning at 10:00
a.m. when the House of Representatives
comes in this morning and we're back in
our studio this morning camille polly is
back with us she's going to be joining
us for 45 more minutes taking your phone
calls this morning anything you found
out in the papers during the time or any
story that you found that interested you
now I find out interesting this article
about a million-year-old skull is found
near the Red Sea and I'm very interested
in science and archaeology and again
this is a part of what I think is
missing from a lot of the humanities
education now in the elite schools i
television is filling the gap here to
the programs of Discovery Channel and of
a
a network and so on which talk about
ancient culture I think that we need a
radical reform of Education to to
highlight the ancient history a
worldwide ancient history and also
science and this again it's science is
constantly being questioned in the
postmodern postmodernist and
postdoctural ideology of the at least
school I love this kind of intersection
of ancient anthropology and and and you
know to try to find little details that
that show that perhaps the accounts of
the wanderings of the of the of the
Hebrews and the old testament are based
on fact or who was the Pharaoh of the
Exodus
that kind of thing I find absolutely
fascinating and the more I think
discussion of the Bible that there is
for me even as a literary document the
better that whether we as an atheist I
think that the Bible as a collection of
poetry and of parable and of instruction
is one of the greatest works of art in
the world and we I think the people who
study the Bible find it infinitely
refreshing even if you don't accept the
actual existence of God
Michael Kaminski senior has this email
for you miss Polly Oh what do you think
of the current hysteria on smoking in
this country ah I am happy to take a pro
tobacco position here I am so sick and
tired of this campaign against tobacco
and people are carrying on taking this
kind of you know take on platforms
against tobacco we have far greater ills
in the world
you cannot stop people from Auto
medicating themselves from from altering
their psychic states tobacco is a far
better substance for young people then
it the kinds of drugs they're taking cat
tranquilizers like Special K or are
they're killing themselves by taking
things from under mothers as you know
kitchen sink and huffing on the spray
you can't stop that tobacco in fact
concentrates the mind refines the
consciousness the overall benefits of
tobacco in the last several hundreds of
years in terms of how tobacco has helped
scholarship editorial projects in the
middle of the night helping to people if
people think and to paint and to create
and to make films and so on
this tobacco crusade is insane its
diversion away from the real
psychological and spiritual ills of this
culture another thing and I'm on the
South are you a smoker by the way I
because I'm now 51 years old and so on I
type like just very moderately have the
occasional cigarette or cigar I love
tobacco I think that that pure tobacco
not the kind of tobacco that's in the
adulterated form with some 90 different
chemicals that is manufactured with the
filters also and I think that that's bad
appear tobacco is a Native American herb
okay it has been used passing the pipe
and so on is ago is gone on in rituals
and this song is continent for for
untold many centuries but the kind of
infantilization of the young people
carrying on about how many young people
are starting to smoke everyday the way
to kids are denied the right to drink
okay you think you can send them to war
okay and so on baby you can't let them
drink I think that is that I've been
awful there's an awful backlash kids
like a lot either for them to pop pills
and take the worst kind of drugs I think
that it alcohol and tobacco use in
moderation are in fact civilization
enhancing Panama's Panama City Beach
Florida on a conservative line good
morning good morning I would just like
to commend miss Paley on her
individuality and her impressive
independence thank you it's so
refreshing myself as an Objectivist as a
reader vine R and there are some things
where miss Polly it doesn't really agree
but she's on the right track and I would
like to commend her individuality it's
really refreshing and she's the type of
woman that I would love thank you people
have many people have commented on the
resemblance between me and Iran to was a
very important intellectual just before
I came to college in the middle of the
1960's for for people in the 1950s a
very conformist era apparently Iran had
had an incredible liberating effect on
people's minds but there are many areas
of agreement that we have and I think
it's because we have common sources we
read the same sorts of romantic
theorists and in the philosophy of
Nietzsche and so on we differ on some
things for example even though I you
know I don't go to church I have great
respect for religion and Iran like the
great Simone de Beauvoir the feminist in
French intellectual attention
religion as as part of a kind of the
rudimentary phase of culture there's a
kind of rationalist bias in both Iran
and Simone de Beauvoir that I I don't
have much patience for I have to say
overall because I believe that the
greatest truths about life cannot fully
be expressed in words I think that
intuition and what the religious people
call faith is also extremely important
Jeff Baldwin email says that talking
about Hillary Clinton here he has a
paragraph ahead of he says no matter
what Hillary Clinton says after her
White House date she will always be
known as a woman who sold her soul for a
man who has no soul well unfortunately
Hillary Clinton has husband forced into
a kind of secondary position here she
did use a man after all to gain power
she did not go the ideal feminist route
of seeking power on her own on the other
hand again I still feel that once the
Clintons are gone from the White House
that Hillary will be freer to speak her
mind and that she can be a formidable of
speech giver the kind of role she played
for example at the Beijing a UN
conference on women's rights and so on I
think is a kind of a prefiguration of
the the leadership role that I expected
to play she and she saw a relatively
young woman I think that she will be a
great force for improvement of women's
law around the world on the liver align
Gary in Georgia your next good morning
good morning I'd like to comment on the
istic amendment as nearly as I can see
that approaches fascism fascism is
trying to impose an individual thoughts
on an entire society and that's that's
what they do the entire Christian Right
movement appears to me to be and
certainly this mystic amendment I'd also
like to say that I think it's time that
we begin to that we start taxing the
churches in this country we could the
government could raise an enormous
amount of revenue and the churches are
interfering in affairs of state whether
they admit to it or not and I think that
the enormous amount of money could be
raised by taxing them just like we tax
corporations and individuals Thanks
you know we can forget how how important
preachers were in progressive movements
in the last 200 years it was preachers
who led the opposition to slavery in the
19th century Martin Luther King was a
preacher Jesse Jackson is a minister and
so on so I think that overall in history
yes in European culture there was a very
queasy intermixture of church and state
but we don't have that here on the
country I think our problems are more on
the level of a spiritual vacuum that the
young are experiencing so I think that
the ethical side of the culture needs to
be built up a bit more on the op-ed page
of the Los Angeles Times this morning is
a piece written by two senators Dianne
Feinstein and Robert Torricelli talking
about James Hormel who is the person who
has been nominated to be the ambassador
to Luxembourg but his his nomination is
questioned for many reasons but one was
because he's almost sexual they write
this should a man be denied the
opportunity to serve a US ambassador to
Luxembourg because he's gay and he says
by blocking the nomination of Hormel the
Republican Party is in danger of
becoming the party of prejudice and
bigotry they put the bipartisan
commitment to Jefferson's call for equal
opportunity for all in special privilege
for none in jeopardy true reaction to
that well I think high-level people who
are gay should be allowed to serve
everywhere in the military or in
politics or in diplomacy but I think
that the questions that are being raised
on legitimate ones to what extent is
this man I don't know it seems to be a
very competent man to what extent is he
kind of intricate association with the
worst kind of gay activism in this
country I think again as an open lesbian
I say I do not want a representative of
of this very rigid and strident kind of
gay activism which sees bigotry
everywhere in the language used there I
find offensive okay the idea that that
moral and ethical people who are the
basis of their religion find
homosexuality ethically abhorrent the
idea that they are bigots okay is one of
the most the stupidest okay and most
inflammatory sorts of use of language
that you know that I think the worst
part of gay activism so it's up to mr.
Walia to to make it clear to what extent
does his homosexuality belong to
private life word belongs or into what
extent is he going to be an ambassador
for for a coterie at a very arrogant
coterie in this country that I'm very
glad has lost a lot of prestige in
recent years when did you discover your
lesbian is he well I mean I was a very
odd character I mean I think that I was
born in the wrong era oh ma so that my
kind of aggressive way of being a girl
was simply not fashionable in 1950 so
you can see very early on my desire to
to masquerade as like in Halloween ages
5 6 7 8 I'm like I'm a Roman soldier I'm
a matador I'm Napoleon page eight and
not many eight-year-old girls have a
Napoleon complex was a young point I
think I just was constantly fighting
against thee did the restrictions of
doors de America where a girl had to be
kind of obedient and quiet and seek
popularity and so on so I I'm not sure
you know in another kind of a culture I
might have been a nun in another culture
I might have been you know I might have
married and like my grandmother's would
say if you were married your husband
would either beat you or kill you he
would say because I was like just
refused to obey so I think I just an odd
character I don't fit into you know
normal special convention from the
conservative line New York City good
morning good morning I'm enjoying
Mississippi but speaking of arrogance
it's just slightly off-topic to say the
least I have an op-ed from David E
kendall yesterday's New York Times
commenting on ken starr's allusion to
kill a mockingbird by harper ibly and he
makes certain points that there are
procedural protections of the Bill of
Rights that afforded to a client and
that Judge Starr in effect has made
insidious encroachments and he bullets
about six points about a few which I
wish to just comment the distortion by
mr. Kendall is to lead the allusion to
the American people who were I guess not
a slightly ignorant of the procedures
that a prosecutor has under the Bill of
Rights he cites the taped conversations
the interview of the mother the
a book receipts and so forth the real
distortion and the real encroachment has
been by mr. Kendall and mr. Clinton
where they have formulated and
manufactured law at a whole court the
protective function of the Secret
Service unknown the the broadening of
executive privilege to include aides
attorney-client privilege for an
attorney that is being paid by the
public this is a disgrace
this is shameless and the continued
character assassination of a judge
stopped a solicitor general is unseemly
Thanks Thank You New York City Oh Oh a
number thinks they come in there
unfortunately a judge star has played
into the hands of his critics that you
know the obviously I mean the assault on
his character which has been going on
for some time I think most people in the
in the country just reading the
newspapers would have no independent
view of justice are accepting so far as
what he puts forward I think that you
know that sort of like wandering out of
his house of having those impromptu
sorts of press conferences in the
morning that way he seemed to be smiling
mildly at the same time that all these
traumas were occurring downtown I think
the PR game has been very much won on
the Democratic side if the only judge
star had presented himself in a more
serious way to show the gravitas of the
law and also if only he had concentrated
his energies on this very important job
instead of paralyzing the nation I don't
think he should have been having a doing
independent legal work during this
period he has left himself open I have
no reason to question judge Starr's
ethics he's left himself open to this
kind of a charge but I also certainly
agree that claim for example that the
Secret Service should not be should be
beyond subpoena power
what is this the praetorian guard again
since when is there a special class of
person at armed guard around the leader
okay who is sworn to personal loyalty to
that leader as a student of ancient
history that makes me very nervous
Auburn Hills Michigan on the moderate
line good morning hello mr. Pelley
uncanny good morning
mr. Pelley I'm only calling on the
moderate line because I can't figure out
what liberal-conservative I mother I
have admired your work tremendously I
was a little girl I was born in 1956 and
so I grew up able to be girly and also
have the advantages of being able to
speak my mind and do what I want however
is an adult I'm finding that's not quite
so easy I wrote a novel putting for some
of the sexual competition differences
between men and women and I I've had a
real hard time getting it sold I've had
editors say things like but but that's a
rape and I read it and I say well it's
kind of a rape but those things go on oh
but we can't have that in the book and
you know we can't have kids smoking
marijuana in the book and we can't have
hockey players that's too macho to macho
you can't write about that and I just
like you to know that I studied the
classics on my own and I wonder if you
have any advice for me
I am I certainly would like to hear it
or if this where you're teaching right
now some perhaps I could communicate
with you thank you I hang up well I just
say in general for people who are
struggling along as writers and so on I
think I'm a good role model because I
struggled for years without being able
to to get published it was a terrible
grueling experience I was 43 finally did
I get my first book accepted and I
published you finally Yale University
people took it took a chance on it okay
but this is like an enormous book by you
know a very strange provocative book
with a lot of anti pc ideas and it was
they really took a great risk on and I'm
very happy actually with a woman from an
editor from the south and interestingly
a southern lady of the old school is the
one who first saw that you know the
potential value in my work you would
think would be the opposite you think
some sort of cutting edge every one
guard person we knew we would see all
these things but I would just say that
anyone who has a talent whatever that
might be in the arts just has to
continually practice that craft you must
continue just go on on and on
I just worked and I worked and I worked
and I never gave up I see so many
examples including among my friends of
people who after s the rejections start
coming in the nose and lose spirits they
get demoralized and you must what you
want to say is I'm putting the craft in
the development of my town above
recognition from the outside world and
if you do that just follow your dreams
follow your vision over time if you work
hard enough on and you can be reward I
still am a good example of that finally
to be able to practice my my craft of
writing and get it get it accepted it's
like it's take such a joy in that being
able to be published after being
unpublished for so long have you ever
done any videos I can say how you could
and I've done again I've done quite a
few videos with in collaboration with
other people I just started and in
videos I did it suddenly with a famous a
New York drag queen and Glenda orgasm
and we sort of went around downtown New
York and visited a little tour that's
quite populous and shown abroad I've
done little cameos and movies like about
it pat pat it's pat who is the the
androgynous character pet yes madam
I have playing a cameo in the new movie
Henry fool it's called I just won the
writing award at can I haven't seen it
yet I think they came so I enjoy doing
that I think I'm a great follower of
Andy Warhol who is some my god from from
the 1960s I believe in this kind of
intermixture of culture of video and
film and in the arts and literature I
think that is the interdisciplinary mix
of the 21st century
Portland Oregon on the liberal line good
morning yeah I first of all I wanted to
say that she misses Talia is our miss
Dahlia is a mesmerizing individual very
highly intelligent and just a joy to
watch and listen to the only thing I
wanted to say is an ultra liberal SDS ex
member from University of Hawaii and now
living in Oregon and so forth but I
wanted to comment on tobacco
I really have looked at the political
ramifications that whole industry and
the cancer element and so forth and with
all due respect for civil liberties etc
and being able to do what you want to do
and so forth and so on I think that
that's fine and dandy but I don't I hate
to hear you can
donut because of health element and
that's just about all I wanted to say if
you're brilliant thank you
well I think my issue is that why are
there so many drugs that are being
pushed okay by the group by the company
great companies and corporations like
ritalin for example why so many millions
of school children on Ritalin I think
that tobacco is far better for even if
it ends up in you having cancer in
middle age than Ritalin which which was
flattens the emotions and energy level
of so many you know rambunctious young
people in the classroom notes I think
God ritalin wasn't available in my
period I think my my teachers would have
given that to me I would not be writing
any books right now that my I would be
like just I'm getting along well with
everyone else and be able to sit still
in a classroom I think that that sort of
thing I don't I don't agree with prozac
but the thing is I am a product of the
nineteen sixty generation when so many
people were taking drugs all around me I
did not take drugs because that is not
my particular physiology but I am see I
think everyone has the right to do what
they want to take good to take any
psyckadeli to take any drug but then you
must accept the consequences that's what
I'm saying
take your drug of choice but you should
not be in charge of the thing the
machinery of a locomotive hurtling
through space and carrying innocent
passengers I think I think those people
even though I'm a libertarian should be
willing to subject themselves to it to a
urinalysis
even on a week weekly basis on the other
hand anyone has the right to destroy
himself or herself I Quebec Oh actually
it's much more helpful in advancing your
your mind as an intellectual as you as a
writer as an artist as even as a person
is driving a bus okay then let's say
ritalin Ritalin or prozac or those
things that like that there are the
kinds of quaaludes they make you get
along with everyone else but turns you
into a kind of cockadoodle ending turns
you into in it removes your
individuality I'm for individuality as a
libertarian Robert Rowland from
Providence Rhode Island has this email
we would miss palea debate Gloria
Steinem and she agreed well I don't
think correspondent has many ideas left
debate I think the time to have debated
for would have been 20 years when I was
a great fan of Gloria Steinem in the
beginning I want make that clear I
thought
she was excellent in when she first came
on the scene in the late 60s and early
70s I think her the foundation of Miss
magazines it was a very important thing
even though Miss magazine exiled from
its pages any dissident feminists like
myself and therefore postponed the great
kind of revision of feminism was going
on the 1990s in fact when I remember
Time magazine had a kind of a survey who
would be a good candidate for the first
woman president I wrote in and I said
Gloria Steinem with her beauty dimmed so
I've been bitterly disappointed with the
way that Gloria Steinem allowed herself
to become a kind of tool of the
northeastern elite in the way she and
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Committee and so on they just are so
intertwined in what I felt was you know
a way that his tests kept feminism back
and damaged feminism and certainly her
attitude toward me when I came on the
scene comparing me to Hitler comparing
my book sexual persona to mine comes
what are we talking about here okay when
you have people leaving the feminist
movement to are who are you know who
have no respect for the truth st. Paul
Minnesota you're next good morning good
morning first of all I'd like to thank
miss palea for her work especially for
the chapter in sexual persona on Russo
and sod you articulated for me my
defense faction with or so that I've had
for years his sort of a rosy view of
nature with children frolicking in the
daisies and I think you're just a
position of him with thought is just
brilliant thank you my question though
is about a very popular figure who I
don't think you've talked about and I
see a lot of similarities between the
two of you and this is dr. Laura
Schlessinger ah and you both have very
vibrant personalities and of course both
are of the italian-american heritage so
I'm curious any thoughts or observations
about her and her popularity yes a
number of people have certainly
commented that I think that this is the
number of us of the figures are just
wrong talking women who suddenly emerge
in the in the middle of the 1990s by
possibly our ancestors oh is Ann Landers
I think Ann Landers who I still read in
the Syracuse newspaper okay with her
column that kind of a voice I think was
very influential on me she was a no wake
up and smell the coffee so I think you
were depressed we can hear the origins
of our of dr. Laura's and my voice and
in
and I think that something with
no-nonsense sort of like you know stop
whining get off your Duff you know stop
blaming other people energize yourself
and it's a very bracing you know I'm
driving the card I had I hear her doctor
Laura on and she's like laughing she's
people calling they're weeping on the
phone inductor Laura laughing I think
that's the proper proper attitude so in
it and as you italian-american added to
it or pick yourself up you're a you know
get back to work and stop complaining
just you know attitude toward life which
is which is confrontational life is an
adventure and songs alright I think dr.
Laura's been enormous ly positive affect
Atlanta you're next in the moderate line
good morning good morning Camille I will
need to call I and just tell you how
much I appreciate your work I just
discovered you in the past few years and
it's just been a delight thank you I
look so much to all of your work oh one
question I had was I wondered what your
take is on all the children who are
committing these horrible crimes in
these high schools by coming in and
taking out their frustrations on other
children so to speak to me where I don't
know if this is what you think but you
wonder if this is just is quote the
breakdown in the family or if if they
just left so much this is so lonely I
was a latchkey kid but I had a lot of
support from my family and from my
neighbors and friends and so I think
sometimes by just saying oh they're home
and we don't care and you know nobody's
paying any attention I think that's an
easy out and I do think everybody has to
be responsible Thanks Atlanta yes I
think well certainly the number one
influence here I don't think it's the
popular culture or violence in the
popular culture but rather there is some
sort of breakdown in the family they
there is a a lack of an adequate role
model particularly I think in the father
on the father's side it's up to fathers
to show what is the honorable behavior
for young boys and let's not let's not
forget it's not kids per se who are
committing these acts it really is boys
with the guns in the old days in the in
the period just before the Industrial
Revolution young
and had a way to seek identity by just
leaving home you could go off and and
and get on a freighter or you go around
the world on a whaling ship or or go to
war and right now I think you know the
culture is such that there's no room for
for development of an independent
masculine identity this is a terrible
problem and there are a number of new
studies that are pending and about you
know coming out on boys you know the
very distinguished christina hoff
sommers for example is right now writing
a book about the war on boys has been
going on in feminism wheatley we've been
saying farm with too much attention to
girls and their problems and not enough
attention to boys how difficult it is to
be a man is a very difficult thing
through history I do to make that
passage from boyhood to manhood it's
always that every culture usually have
these strange dangerous sorts of rituals
that you know the boys undergo to be
taken into the world of men but what if
there is no world of men now what is it
to be a boys a very liquid thing we're
not women our advantage and in the kinds
of behavior that women are good at
sitting cooperatively in an office space
sitting quietly in a classroom and so on
there's no room for four boys to have
dignity so we've got to look back at
this again I think that boys are in
crisis Montville New Jersey on the liver
line good morning morning how you doing
I'm thanks good listen I just really
need to talk about this tobacco thing a
little bit I understand what you're
trying to say but to like and tobacco I
mean to say tobacco is a mind-altering
product that makes people more creative
and all sorts of things like that is
likening it to heroin or LSD or anything
else I mean it's interesting I I know
what you're saying about tobacco but to
some degree what went on with the
tobacco industry is one of the greatest
conspiracies of the 20th century and I
am NOT a conspiracy theorist by any
means you're talking about a group of
people who knew tobacco would cause
cancer who knew nicotine was addictive
and at one point I mean we've got
documentation now that shows they were
actually spiking cigarettes with
nicotine to make sure people weren't
going to leave it know you know I mean
why don't we just say that it's as bad
as everything else it's not a matter of
sure people have the choice to smoke and
people can go home and blow their brains
out I mean that's fine but if you think
about what I do I do think that there is
an element of personal responsibility
here my father what do we do often
that when he was in World War 2 even at
that point the soldiers call cigarettes
coffin nails everyone has known for most
of the century that they are the bad
effects of smoking over over the long
run now now this one is I think it's
quite wrong to be blaming the tobacco
industry for people's individual
addictions I think that I think it is an
addictive substance it you know I think
that it I'm more concerned rather than
the doctoring of cigarettes with the
excess nicotine I'm more concerned about
the multiple chemicals that are in there
that prevent you know cigarettes for
example for continued to burn and cause
couch fires that sorts of things there's
all kinds of poisons in the tobacco
smoke that aren't related to tobacco so
I hope that you can see that I'm taking
a pro tobacco position I have not taken
a pro tobacco industry position
necessarily but again as a libertarian I
feel that all these things have to be
left in individual hands I still believe
that is better for young people to be
smoking than it is for them to be taking
the myth of drugs that they are taking
you cannot believe the drugs they are
taking marijuana over the long term I
believe that marijuana should be
legalized by the way I that should be
controlled the way alcohol and tobacco I
don't take it by the other hand I seem
very pretentious effects on the undie
but you know reasoning powers of the
brain over long term from marijuana now
from tobacco tobacco enhances marijuana
dulls it marijuana does help I think
jazz performance in jazz composition and
there's certain areas of Arts creativity
I think marijuana helped but not when it
comes to reading and writing and memory
and retention alright so again I think
tobacco overall has has been a positive
influence on culture fifteen minutes
left with Camille Talia and if you have
any other stories that you have not had
a chance to bring up this morning we
certainly can do that and we'll take a
couple more calls what's the one you
went up this sort of excellence
photograph okay why do you want to talk
about well in Monica Lewinsky with yet
another group of all you know
middle-aged men I'm you know I just find
this bit tiresome Monica Lewinsky
floating with that sort of Mona Lisa
smile around with these older men I
think that feminism has really been set
back by this kind of image of a young
girl there was an attempt early on to
portray Monica Lewinsky as someone who
entered in which is a blog post if you
can think for herself she's old enough
she has a consensual relationship with
that you know was so with her with her
employer and
this vision for the past few months
always with either the father figure or
the or the paternalistic lawyer sitting
in restaurants quietly smiling and
thinking good god what is this she's
like a Geisha just like a Geisha being
dragged around and there she is once
again okay with it with the men with
their always with the men and she's
perfectly capable of making decisions on
her own she didn't have to be this
prisoner this odalisque that she has
been the past few months she could have
gone got off on her own and got her own
privacy I just think this is a you know
it's been a disaster what's going to
take a while to for us to work out what
exactly were the dynamics of choice or
coercion in her particular Adventures of
the past few years Marietta Georgia on
the conservative line your next good
morning oh yes I'm a first-time caller
welcome nervous I'm a conservative and
I'm a member of the Christian Right and
I just want to say that this is the best
program I've ever seen on c-span
I've really enjoyed listening to Camille
and I have two questions why do you
think so many conservatives agree with
your point of view and what do you think
about Clinton going to China with all of
their human rights abuses oh well well
secondly I'm very troubled by the
administration's attitude toward China
and the enemy for heaven's sakes we
destabilize all of Asia okay by causing
this new essence causing this arms race
now with nuclear tests going off in
India and Pakistan into the Clinton
administration has been strongest of
course in domestic issues and it's
ignoring of the foreign policy stage
lenient could lead us to the brink of
World War 3 I'm very concerned I don't
think obviously that chai that that our
president should be going to chairman
square if the atrocity that occurred
there in during the great period the
domani Democratic uprising there that
was so that was so brutally squashed but
then the other question was and why do
you think so many conservatives agree
with oh yes okay well I I believe I'm
simply a voice of common sense but I
don't think that because there was agree
with me on some issues but they
certainly don't on others for example I
have taken a radically Pro prostitution
position for example I you know I favor
the legalization of prostitution you
know and I well I think they again as a
libertarian I think the government has
absolutely no right to intervene in
private behavior I respect
best prostitutes as sex workers I think
that if feminism was worth its salt it
would it would have acted to help to
unionize prostitutes and to help protect
also the rights of strippers I favor the
strip clubs or the whole areas of my
thinking where conservatives are
uncomfortable I think that I'm just one
of those figures of the 1990s there's
there a number of us okay who have tried
to to look again at the polarization of
the political landscape this liberal
versus conservative kind of dichotomy
which dates all the way back in certain
ways to the period just after the French
Revolution I think that no longer can
really it's not longer adequate for for
the new global stage of politics of the
21st century Clarksburg West Virginia on
the moderate line good morning good
morning miss Kali I just I've got to say
you are wonderful absolutely wonderful
and but I'll make the comment that I've
had which I've been trying to get
through for about half an hour with but
but it's worth it your your stance on
tobacco is spectacular it's wonderful
and I can just imagine Henry Waxman
somewhere just having a little hissy fit
you know over over you're actually
taking a sensible position on this and
the question I had there was an article
in Vanity Fair recently it was by a
feminist and it was about speaking of
the northeastern and lead establishment
it was about a gathering of a luncheon
of some kind in New York City with Erica
young and there were you know a couple
other authors and they were just giddy
talking and speculating about the
president Monica Lewinsky and what may
have happened and I mean it was just so
ridiculous but I was curious if you've
seen that article and if you had any
comment on it well actually Marjorie
Williams it was actually superb general
article when the best I have ever seen
and I you know I and I left a call to
her to compliment her there was a
brilliant art about people should see it
Roger Williams account of a cup from a
liberal feminist point of view of the
disastrous failings of the feminist
leadership in being able to to judge
these various cases of sexual harassment
for example even though I favor sexual
harassment guidelines are moderately
applied I did not agree with the with
the canonization of an either hill I
felt that it was a fascist exercise to
bring a man into public ridicule and the
way the Clarence Thomas was to ask him
to recount
time conversations from 10 years before
I do not believe Anita Hill was sexually
a Harris that is not a verbal you know
discussions or bantering conversations
to me not sexual harassment because I
think that that was a kind of perversion
of it then when Paula Jones came on the
scene I was the only leading feminist
that in 1994 that went out to support
her or I supported her I felt that she
had a far greater claim okay to having
been sexually harassed if what she
alleged was true if indeed her ultimate
employer dropped his ass in front of her
and what was essentially her workplace
with atrocious in the failure of the
feminist leadership at that time in 1994
to come to her defense okay and instead
to react in conservative versus liberal
terms show then in fact the feminist
leadership has basically been pawned all
along haven't they I was a very corrupt
Democratic National Committee and now
with Monica Lewinsky case now I've been
saying all along I said in that in that
my appearance was on Larry King when I
supported them at that time 94 apologize
abut so that time that I want I want a
high libido president doesn't bother me
at all if a man has in the European
style has many mistresses as long as he
honors his wife at home and so on what I
object to in this whole allegations
about about the amount of lives we
affair is that the Oval Office it
doesn't belong to any private individual
okay so it's being used for assignation
for heaven's sakes I mean get out of the
White House go have a weekend go to
Georgetown party okay you know pursue
your your affairs and they have
sophisticated way that Prince Charles
has for heaven's sakes and Monica
Lewinsky
what kind of step back that Erica Jong
okay when it was not could not she's
defending Monica Lewinsky as sort of
like this like feel-good 1960s type
person okay what sad is what what
honored did she have was was she if the
story is true was she ever given status
within Clinton circle with his friends
as his mistress
oh you know what what benefits she ever
get she was kept in a back door way used
to service Clinton in the historical
space of the White House if true it is
disgraceful
it is disgrace at the same time I say to
Clinton go out have a thousand you know
out looks at your disposal is it is a
disgrace now that is where the these
feminists in New York really have shown
how M
people they are to analyze the workplace
okay this was a workplace issue this
isn't just about Monica Lewinsky finding
herself for having saying that she was
abused it is outrageous okay for the
interns at the White House to be used as
if they were I said to Vanity Fair like
a dessert cart Norfolk Virginia on the
liberal line the morning yes good
morning miss paglia I'm a historian
actually not his going but a history
professor in Norfolk Virginia and I have
a theory that I would really like your
opinion on do you believe that civic
humanism has been lost in Western
culture that is to say the concept and
certainly on the same age as you are so
I remember the draft and the loss of the
draft and John Kennedy I think might
have been on the right track when he
said the draft doesn't mean just
fighting wars but Civic humanism that is
you join the Peace Corps you join what
was a an attempt now to bring in
AmeriCorps but you join something men
women not the way we knew it at that
certain age where you give something
back early on where you identify plus
the integration of all levels of society
together
no one copying out everyone going
through this process and then coming
back and doing your education your
university why have we lost that I think
American culture has lost a bonding in
the last 30 years it's a very
interesting question that you raised in
fact it came up last night at the
National Press Club after I gave my
speech one of the questions was this
that if there were a draft would I
believe that women should be drafted I
believe yet it is about time again that
we think of this asking young people to
serve the nation I think that there is a
first of all you I think are you aware
of you must be as in many of the elite
schools that are kind of an attitude of
you know anti Americanism is encouraged
as a matter of fact in young people it's
not chic to be patriotic oh yeah now I
come out of a generation my father
fought in World War two and my uncles
fought in World War two and we are what
we have intense patriotism intense love
of America we realize what America has
done for our family and it was very
difficult for my family because Italy
was on the opposite side so essentially
we know we we've met the people who my
family who went to war fought against
their own heritage and now in Europe or
you know or in the Pacific and I think
that that we really need to to ask for
the young men and young women to give to
give something back to its a nation I
think it would give it a spree decor I
think I think
an excellent idea and I'm hoping perhaps
some political leader will come along
who will be who through it would he'll
have fine the rhetoric to be able to
inspire such idealism just facts as a
child of immigrants who made it on their
own by working long hours and without
any government handouts what is your
philosophy about legal immigrants
receiving food stamps and other
financial renumeration well I mean I
hate to make take a position on this
question right now it seems to me so
complicated very very complicated yes I
don't suddenly like a situation where
we're starting to close the borders and
seem like well this is it this is the
this is the group that we're going to be
stuck with that I you know I think that
we really I think need a kind of very
high levels and Commission I hate go
ahead and call for another government
boondoggle to explore all these issues I
don't like the kind of tide of
anti-immigrant feeling that's rising in
the country right now
I think it's pernicious considering the
though the welcome and America gave to
my own family pittsfield massachusetts
on the conservative line good morning
yes I've been enjoying this very much
this is the first time I've ever called
in welcome and I was wondering have you
ever read the female of the species by
what your Kipling where hmm no I know
where dude tell us about it I don't
remember reading it but the female of
the species by what dude Kipling are you
familiar with that I don't remember
reading it tell us more about it
well in there he states that the female
whether in the wild an animal or whether
a human as is the most ferocious and
that in one part he says but the female
that God gave him every fiber of her
frame proves how launched for one sole
issue armed an engine for the same and
to serve that single issue unless the
generations fail the female of the
species must be deadlier than the male
but as yourself but when day then matron
lacking and she strides unclaimed to
claim her right as femme endure and her
equipment is the same and therefore the
female is very capable of wiping out the
male and she has proved to do it to this
day
well I'm naturally very interested in
that that's one of the themes of my work
actually they defense at all the woman
failed to man and I think that that's
one of the issues I have brought into
1997 ISM which before this had been
talking about woman as powerless and man
having all the power in history and I
have shown that on the country to me the
female of the species is far more potent
than than men and all men know it I
think Seattle Washington on the moderate
line good morning
Oh so you lean epochal yeah how are you
this morning
fine thank you you know you're
fascinating I have a love-hate
relationship with you but I think you're
brilliant Thanks
you know you uh remind me a little bit
of very Goldwater ah and since I and I
did some work for him in 1964 and I have
a pin from him says if I were 21 I'd
vote for Barry unfortunately I was
eligible for the draft but not to vote
and what do you see a service what do
you see is the comparisons there well
because you're a libertarian you tell
like it is mm-hmm you're you're you're
right on the money and I'd like to know
how many misdemeanors constitute a high
crime before the process kicks in
talking about the president yeah Wow
I don't you think we've lowered our bar
of standards in this country well I
myself feel that so far I'm not sure
that we that there's enough grounds for
impeachment of the president I think
there are grounds for censure of the
president I think that if we just could
get to that point of having some
resolution of censure and then get
beyond this I think that if it's true
this aborting a perjury has gone on
obviously it's going to have to be
worked out you know in the in the next
few months the severity of the of the
misdemeanors but I want just the other
thing about Barry Goldwater I happen to
I remember very well the campaign where
does was in the Northeast were given to
understand that the Barry Goldwater was
a dangerous fanatic they would take the
you know the world to the edge of war
and so on
I remember having seen him in person
once my mother and I were visiting
Washington and we were looking down into
the Senate chambers and I was stunned at
his charisma I have never forgotten it
aha what a powerful man he was and I
realized having seen him in person just
for that one moment and seen him in
action what how how badly had been
served okay by that particular campaign
at that time I think in retrospect we
can see just in the the footage has been
run or last few days since his death
that this was a man of stature and
independent voice of a kind that we're
not getting in our politics right now
I'm very concerned about the kinds of
your pygmy lightweights okay that are
are entering into politics I think you
know people are being discouraged from
from entering politics because of the
abuse that the political process
subjects themselves is - is there a
politician out there that allows you if
any I am no but I'm still hoping that
there's a rising generation of women
okay then who are who are learning you
know the political ropes and that and
will eventually come to powers I'm
hoping we're right now we're in a kind
of vacuum alas a vacuum of people I had
hoped great deal from like Senator
Dianne Feinstein who I was a supporter
of even aa resident of state of
Pennsylvania seemed to recede you know
from the political process and in recent
years and christine Todd Whitman even
though I'm not a Republican I felt that
she had a future ahead of her and she
was there health problems or through her
marginalization as a moderate the
Republican party seems to receive it as
well and I think that they adjusted the
amount that politics takes out of you in
the in the pretty constant need to get
money I think is draining the idealism
of our politicians I think we have much
to be concerned about we don't want a
politics is being run by the by the by
television salon magazine is also sub
place that you can find the works of
Camille Thalia how often every other
week and then my column is always up and
all my columns are available on the
archive of salon magazine Alexandria
Virginia last call oh my god last call
first of all when I first saw you on a
Tom Schneider show late at night it was
love at first sight oh thank you I'm a
little older than you generation
probably similar generations too old for
Korea too young too young for Korea to
alter Vietnam I called
mostly to adulate you but also to ask
you how do you manage to be a
intellectual without intellectualizing
and how do you manage all this energy of
yours without without drugs you you are
genuine real I want to dance with you I
want to talk with you I want to
introduce you to my children and my
family well thank you I think the the
energy is Italian adrenaline there's no
doubt have you ever seen me like a
little a town hero then like that yeah
yeah yeah when I was young I was like
Wilfred quiet when I was very little and
then burst out at puberty I think but
the little Italian widows are run around
you know they're like they're like 85
years old they have a black hair net
they're like run right through you and
knock you off the knees and some with
spring energy day I think Mediterranean
women have that's that's where it comes
from
and as for I believe that intellectual
should be able to express his or her
ideas in common everyday language I get
that from the fact that I came from I
came from the people that might my
implement from an immigrant path I
believe that academics who use a
pedantic jargon filled language are just
they're incompetent they're incompetent
in those snobbish I despise them
Richard strong Tampa Florida last this
last email most would call me a white
male Christian conservative nonsmoker
non drinker homophobic close-minded the
problem is you haven't ruffled my
feathers in fact I love you in your
opinion how do you how do you how do you
do how do you reconcile that I have fans
all over across the whole political
spectrum it just because I'm like this
is this voice of common sense I think
I'm a true American woman number one and
when I go abroad it's very clear how
American I am and there's a kind of
constraint and convention I think that
holds back the women everywhere in the
world but in America that's why I hate
the anti-americanism that I hear
everywhere in the Ivy League and so on
okay it's only in America in modern
America that I've been able to be as
free as I am right now and I am a free
speech militant I feel that free speech
is one the great gifts of modern life in
America we have the first in the last
year and there are sin there too in
between this was the first sexual
persona and that was 1990 and this is
the one not yet out again next month and
in in London I'm hoping that that it
will be this book the birds will be
available of course through the into the
internet order things like
um I'm hoping that there will be no
problem getting it but it would be
certainly in America in the bookstores
by the fall published by the British
Film Institute in London and again the
premise it is an interpretation of
Alfred Hitchcock's of the birds every
single detail in and I have tried to
interpret in I revere Alfred Hitchcock
is a great genius of the 20th century
Kamiya Polly is also a professor of
humanities at the University of the Arts
in Philadelphia Pennsylvania thank you
for joining us thank you very much we'll
be right back